you were going by concrete at the time
no no i used to go as beretta what was
it beretta beretta oh [ __ ] i think i
remember yeah and this is how i know
like most of these dudes you know like
bash a lot of people see me doing skits
now with bash or frankie i've known
these guys these artists and it's like
dog i used to open up for these dudes
when i was like you know and like really
in the rap game and then i went from you
know my you know unfortunately my my
brother passed away in 2008 he was like
my hype man my day-to-day manager
everything kind of deal you know and
passed away in 2008 and i decided to
just stop rapping during the time of
like the record time starting to pop
yeah so you so you just getting on the
radio i was getting on the radio i was
trying to do shows i was trying to
travel and you know do my thing
and uh your brother passed and that kind
of inspired you to just walk away from
doing music yeah i was like i'm done
with it you know because i just i just
started you know like you start seeing
like you know people start acting
different you know
and it was
you know i i actually credited like i'm
glad if i if i would have done blown up
then you know i probably would have just
i probably would have killed myself for
something because i wasn't in the right
state i was just i was just being uh you
know i mean imagine being 21 and then
like you have a record on the radio at a
time when having a record on the radio
deal was a big deal huge deal yeah back
then it was a big deal not so much now
yeah so it's like everywhere i went it
was like you know it was like people
already knew who i was and it was you
know people started acting different